the Joe Rogan experience makes me
nervous about hospitals when you hear
about nurses get off on killing people
look every every so often there's some
nurse who just gave people lethal
injections or [ __ ] just one movie makes
a great movie does but you know like by
the way if you're a nurse I'm sure
you're awesome it's not you I love I
love nurses I love doctors all those
people all healthcare practitioners and
first responders or and lawyers yep them
too but there are some dirty people out
there they're monsters just happened to
be nurses right spiders
hunky [ __ ] spiders putting holes in
your leg yeah called my god spider bait
for a loss you didn't live around raus
thanks to you got serious rattlesnakes
man you live well then the rattlesnakes
are pretty they're pretty good about
just letting you know yeah yeah they
just let you know they just kind of go
on their way there they don't really
want anything to do with you know the
the tarantulas same thing they just kind
of go the other way tarantulas look
terrifying
but they're family they're pretty docile
they're pretty cool yeah they they just
hang out they're not like the tarantula
Hawks you gotta watch out for was that
tarantula hawk or is that a giant man be
looking fingering it up [ __ ] these
things what is it
gotta get a photo the world is so scary
did you two people that bear the Florida
in the our by sharks today I'm not sure
which one it is somebody can chime in oh
jesus that thing's big okay yeah I've
seen these things before yeah [ __ ]
that's huge
they like they they find a tarantula
they jump on it
they infect it with their eggs and so
the trench is like I made it out of
there and who wanders off and then dies
and they did Valar bro come out of the
tarantula Oh ain't you dirty [ __ ] yeah
so their thirst their sting is like you
know level 4 top 5 when a bullet ant
like that kind yeah yeah like like a
centipede centipede on the list but like
not above centipede really these things
that's why you have
is that you bro people to bite no that's
me being terrified of Senate bill that's
your right hand right and I know hey you
know what I have no pain now my ring
name yeah that's a baby
no centipedes are just there's those
things like that caused me to shriek
like my grandmother I can jump up on a
on a counter Maynard the set appeared
yeah I could it's got a ring to it I
like it I like it yeah yeah they're
creepy maybe I'll fight Tom Cruise have
you ever seen a centipede attack or
Mouse no but so apparently the
centipedes sting is not as intense as
the as the tarantula hawk from what I
read I don't know I don't know who's
doing this but there's they need to like
I don't know man word hurts what hurts
words the tasers that the pepper spray
get back to yet a certain job how do you
know at a certain moment you know once
you get to that bullet ant level like
how it's supposed to be like getting
your arms slammed in a car door for 24
hours like how do you know there's
something worse than that you have
another one that's really bad too is
like yeah [ __ ] too it also $600 to
get yourself stung by a tarantula hawk
and woman see whatever how long does it
last
I don't know this that's the thing this
is that did it hey guy he has a YouTube
channel right oh yeah what is that guy's
name again coyote yeah
what did he get stop it I was for a
while I think we're supposed to get him
on the podcast what is his name again
coyote what his channel is called brave
wilderness here he goes Oh bang look
he's doing to himself get me get me ah
look at him Wow first I wouldn't even
put that jar back on I'd be like weeping
whoa
coyote Wilson what's his name well that
would say its whole name
coyote gets done poke find out this
gentleman's name cuz I feel like an
[ __ ] now priority Peterson coyote
Orson why I called Karli Wilson
look at him there it's ow that is not
wise yeah but neither is that leather
hat he's wearing so Wow
what are you gonna do the bracelets look
questionable as well I think he said
this was the worst of anything we have
like two-tone pants on some of the pants
the source of anything he's ever done
put it like he goes and finds everything
that's the worst thing you can do and
does the video like this watch him just
deal with it quite a few of those guys
that's a what a weird way to make a
living just get [ __ ] up by nature
works for Johnny Knoxville mm-hmm I want
to show you a video of a centipede
killing a mouse that's what I had here
doesn't show you their horrific
centipede verse typed in there's a whole
bunch of things that pop take your pick
away you wanna go with mouse because
it's particularly aggressive and the way
they attack mice eat mice so although
it's third down third down good watch
this watch this smells like hey I'm just
a mouse I'm kind of cute
just chilling hanging out here in this
weird blue floor I'll [ __ ] Jesus
Christ
the thing about centipedes too is they
don't just say am i hungry no they know
what they do and what they do is [ __ ] up
a mouse that is right out of the movie
alien right oh my god dick the mouse is
like Jesus [ __ ] Jesus look at him he's
already dead I mean that is goddamn
crazy the mouse is way bigger than him
and he's burrowing into his [ __ ]
spine right now it's twitching and
trying to stay alive the thing about it
that's so creepy is it's not necessarily
hungry like it just that's what it does
it sees things it kills it mccall me I'm
here with a mouse like a bison and a 9
year old yeah it's like I'm hearing with
a mouse in this weird little [ __ ]
environment that doesn't seem natural at
all but I'm not gonna think about that
I'm just gonna kill this [ __ ] mouse
that's what's important not not why am I
in this I push me
[Applause]